if you talk about too young if anything
like by kindergarten they're five years
old that's that's that's five prime
years of
sexualizing
that they've missed out on they're
telling us
uh last week we played some clips
first shared and reported by chris
rouffeau of a training session from the
far left lgbt extremist group the
mazzoni center and if you remember this
was a conference attended by
philadelphia teachers and also by kids
and minors were attended invited to
attend this conference as well
and there was a lot of depraved stuff we
don't have to go through all of it but
you can go back and watch that show if
you want to some examples
they had all kinds of you know they had
people presenting information about uh
you know
sex toys and everything else like to
teachers for some reason
and now we have more footage um this is
from
rachel simon she's the woman in the
video
she's a trans affirming quote unquote
psychoanalyst and i want you to listen
to what she says listen
i am rachel simon i use she her pronouns
i am a psychotherapist educator
consultant and author
i run my private practice here in
philadelphia and i am the author of the
every body book which is a
an lgbtq inclusive
um sex ed resource for seven to 12 year
olds i love that you said that this this
talk specifically was geared towards
teens but you're so right that sexuality
education starts
the minute you're born i mean we have
we're born with bodies these bodies are
cool we want to touch our bodies we're
learning about um privacy and you know
being
sexual in public from a very early age
drop the cons of talking about sexuality
with parents and getting our sexual info
from parents in the chat
um because we're getting some of that
embarrassment awkwardness those can be
cons
they don't want to talk about it
homophobic and transphobic ideas from
parents can absolutely be a problem
inescapable judgment
yeah bigoted misinformed parents who
have no idea how to talk about gay sex
they're biased if they are religious it
can be very difficult to get into the
conversation with them
yeah sometimes you can get stonewalled
out of information
so psychotherapist there sorry sorry i
misgendered her as a psychoanalyst she's
a psychotherapist
and uh what's her message well i don't
bother talking to your parents you know
they're religious and bigoted don't
don't don't bother talking to them
uh but sexuality education begins at
birth she says
now i have to keep banging this drum
here because it's important to point out
where this stuff comes from
and that is
and all of the sex ed stuff comes from
alfred kinsey originally and that is
alfred kinsey to a t
that children are sexual
from birth
literally from infancy
and as you're familiar with if you
listen to this show uh and we've talked
about before some of the horrific
details around that
pervert's life uh he he
actually
tried to prove
through sexual experiments on on young
babies that babies are quote sexual from
birth um
and uh
so sexual from birth
so we're gonna do sexuality education
for
infants now
i guess
see we're we're all we're we're buying
the eight ball because we're sitting
here saying
what do you mean
dude sex education in kindergarten this
is ridiculous that's way too young
but what the left is saying is that no
that's too late
you talk about too young if anything
like by kindergarten they're five years
old that's that's that's five prime
years of
sexualizing
that they've missed out on they're
telling us
and then she also says
she gets more and more disturbingly
specific she says that uh from a very
young age we're learning about being
sexual in public
that's what
what are you talking
about but of course nobody
these people they're always running
unopposed as it were and uh you're only
ever going to hear them talking into a
camera
on a conference like this or on stage in
front of like mine a like-minded
audience of degenerates and perverts um
they're never going to put themselves in
a position where there's going to be any
follow-up questions
so they could just say stuff like this
you know because if there was a
follow-up question then the follow-up
would be what no no
back up a second
little kids being sexual in public what
the hell are you saying
explain that to me
is that what you think when you see kids
out in public that's what you think
they're doing
go ahead explain
and we know whatever the explanation is
it's not going to there's there's
there's no way to make that any less
depraved
and this again is this was a training
session
at least in part for
teachers
this is what teachers are being told
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content